all right people we are here at the high
cotton brewing cup and I'm sitting in
front of a very talent comedians and I'm
excited to talk the Toya John
Brad's feat mø Alexander and my man
Cletus is the comedy scene here in
Memphis is it a big scene yeah from when
I first started here at a club the
independent comedy scene came up and
yeah you can book just like open myself
every night of the week will you say
independent you mean self-made rooms
came up and said they couldn't get over
to the club so they started off with
though and now that that's it it's
booming
Danzig oh wow yeah it was a younger guy
here have you found a lot of success my
circulate in those rooms oh yeah I mean
I'm out there almost every night of the
week that that can't be I'm just hitting
every room that I can ask overtime
anywhere because I feel like why turn
down any sort of stage time I like it do
you feel like it's a diverse group of
people why comest a on Midtown nobody
comes to being warrior I think that no I
don't know why company I think we could
benefit if we would take we have the
same goal I remember when I was starting
out the one thing that I wanted to do is
perform for everybody no no and I think
maybe you guys should just try to take
some steps it's a diversifying the rooms
that you guys have my hair because
ultimately we're doing the one thing
that everybody needs that's it
fighting laughter what do you want out
of comedy what's the ultimate goal for
you take you off your spot it's a good
go shoot boys shoot for Cletus
what's that gold man i'ma be honest with
you man I'm trying to get paid right
that stays time that's my gift to the
world like when I make people laugh the
feeling I get back is enough of me catch
now all it is do you like the money
right you need the money to catch up
tension right the money and the ability
to go together but I mean this show is
the first step to more steps to come in
tonight is about you making people
understand of this talent here in
Memphis Tennessee
[Music]